I grew up primarily in suburban New
Jersey,
not far from New York City.
My parents worked.
And I think I'm very much a product of
the middle class to upper middle class
suburban environment that I grew up in
a,
in an environment in which a achievement
in school and achievement in,
uh,
the professional world beyond school
were,
you know,
very,
very high values.
Uh,
and uh,
I think that,
you know,
shaped me a tremendous list.
I usually say that I got into journalism
because the family business,
uh,
my parents met when they were the
success of editors of the undergraduate
newspaper at Nyu where they were both a
commuter students.
Um,
my father went on to spend his entire
career in journalism primary with the
late great,
uh,
New York Herald Tribune and then for 35
years at Time magazine.
So I grew up carrying a little reporters
pad and pencil in my pocket,
just imitating my father and as a child.
For me,
a big adventure was to come into the
city from New Jersey to visit him at the
time and life building and send messages
through the old pneumatic tubes.
And Play Ping Pong in the hallway with
the other journalists,
people who I thought were these exotic
cookie off the wall people.
And I thought it was just the coolest
thing in the world that my father worked
with these people.
Uh,
so as a kid,
I just assumed I was going to become a
journalist because that's what people
did when they got older.
[inaudible].